I'll put this link in this is of course some GitHub
you can access it.
You don't need anything, but I'll share this with you.
Just go through the cells one by one.
So you can see this is the this is what the sigmoid function
does, right it plots it on this on
this s looking.
I mean, this is this this is this you're seeing
them. This is the model plotting. It's not
the actual observations is the model of the observations.
And if you if you draw a line.
you will get this red line, but what the
the expert function does
is
like you're seeing here it will.
push it up to one if it's
if it's a true if it's a truth classification and bring it all the
way down to 0% false classification.
That's really what I try. I mean, I'm trying to speed up
the explanation.
Okay.